[Musica]
immagina se nella tua casa arriva
un'onda alta tre metri
spinta da un vento a 300 chilometri
all'ora quest'onda travolge tutto questo
è quello che è successo nelle filippine
ad haiti questa è una travolge tutto e
tutti i tuoi ricordi le tue foto la tua
casa i tuoi averi tuoi beni e forse
anche i tuoi cari
vengono spazzati via
immagina stai andando a 300 all'ora il
mondo ai tuoi piedi
stai vincendo tutto ti senti padrone di
te stesso e di tutto quello che succede
è tutto sotto controllo
improvvisamente succede qualche cosa che
non avevi previsto e ti trovi in un lato
in cui non ha controllo di nulla
immagina la tua mamma non ti riconosce
più
non sa più chi sei quando ti vedo ti
chiama signorina lei e graziosa mi
ricordo una persona che conoscevo
immagina di essere tu quella persona che
non riconosce più le persone
e i visi che sono attorno a te
qualche volta la malattia fa questo ci
mette in un tunnel in cui non sempre
siamo in grado di vedere la luce il
grande poeta rilke diceva soltanto
quando la sofferenza psichica ci
colpisce possiamo cogliere in noi delle
risorse potenzialmente creatrici non c'è
conoscenza e esperienza creativa senza
sofferenza il nostro corpo la nostra
mente non sono separati
noi siamo il nostro corpo come dice un
grande psichiatra italiano genio bourne
ea ogni malattia
specie se protratta a una risonanza
nella vita psichica perché entriamo in
contatto con la nostra fragilità è una
conoscenza che aiuta a comprendere
meglio le nostre attitudini interiori
noi scopriamo sentimenti emozioni forza
debolezza problemi che altrimenti non
avremmo mai potuto cogliere non avremmo
mai conosciuto il modello medico come la
medicina negli ultimi 100 anni ci ha
insegnato che può essere la medicina
vede il corpo malato con una macchina
guasta qualche cosa in cui io posso
riparare la macchina può ripartire il
modello biomedico negli ultimi 100 anni
ci ha portato risultati strepitosi gli
antibiotici hanno sconfitto le malattie
il modello biomedico funziona benissimo
la chirurgia l'anestesia i progressi
hanno sicuramente portato a un
grandissimo vantaggio per l'uomo per
l'umanità però questo modello biomedico
costo un modello dell'uomo macchina in
un certo senso sta mostrando qualche
limite popolazione mondiale invecchia
per me come medico e uno dei successi
più strepitosi della medicina per molti
per i politici per coloro che devono
organizzare la salute è vista come una
cosa terrorizzante
ma assieme all'invecchiamento io ho
anche un aumento delle malattie croniche
un aumento dell'ipertensione degli abeti
delle malattie cardiologiche
dell'obesità di malattie che restano
soprattutto le malattie del cervello le
malattie neurologiche le malattie
psichiatriche aumentano e sono malattie
per le quali in qualche modo il panorama
cambia non basta più il modello
biomedico perché dove sta la patologia
in gran parte di queste malattie io non
so che cosa togliere non so qual è il
guasto che io posso riparare per far
ripartire questa macchina corpo questa
macchina uomo perfettamente sana
perfettamente indica cosa togliere che
cosa aggiungere e molto difficile curare
oggi spesso significa regolare un
sistema di cui non sappiamo veramente
bene dov'è il guasto è necessario quindi
forse ripensare alla medicina pensare a
una medicina che torni all clean air in
greco clean air vuol dire chinarsi ed è
lì che nasce la medicina clinica
chinarsi a quello che fa il medico
quando si china
verso il paziente e allora e forse è
tempo di pensare che la medicina essi
spazio la prestazione l'efficienza la
tecnologia abbiamo visto prima
la tecnologia può fare delle cose
straordinarie ma la medicina è anche
tempo il tempo della malattia e dal
primato della prestazione quello che lo
spazio ci fa fare la fantastica
progressione dell'umano che è quello che
noi vediamo con i grandi progressi della
medicina forse dovremmo pensare che
potrebbe essere rivalutata allora
un'altra parte la parte del tempo il
tempo inteso come il tempo della
malattia nel quale io ho relazioni il
tempo della malattia che non è un tempo
perso come diceva nietzsche ci si guardi
dal essere malati troppo a lungo
giacché tosto gli spettatori si
impazienti scono a causa dell'obbligo
abituale di mostrare compassione dato
che il mantenere a lungo in se stessi
questo stato costa loro troppa fatica
e allora la passano immediatamente
rendere il rispetto al vostro carattere
con la conclusione che voi meritate di
essere malati e non è più necessario che
noi ci si affatichi con la compassione
tanti anni fa viveva nice ma in realtà
questa impazienza contemporanea è quella
che facilita assolutamente all'entrata
all'interno del nostro pensare del
nostro quotidiano della nostra
contemporanea impazienza quella che
viene chiamata la cultura dello scarto
quella che privilegia l'uomo maschio
quarantenne produttore bello
possibilmente a quella che è la realtà
ognuno di voi quella che è la nostra
realtà una cultura dello scatto c'è già
state c'è sempre ma quello che noi
dobbiamo in qualche modo ricordarci che
non è che è passata
l'uomo perfetto come modello porta avere
una cultura dello scarto qui ora oggi
qui a bergamo qui in italia qui in
europa qui nel mondo la cultura dello
scarto per cui se non sei perfetto tu
sei scarto le persone non sono la
malattia che hanno oggi si festeggia nel
mondo di un certo tipo di persone che
sono abituate a lavorare sulla
disabilità
sedici anni da che lo ms ha detto la
disabilità non è soltanto la malattia
che hai ma è la malattia che hai
nell'ambiente in cui sei e questo
ambiente può essere una barriera e
questo modello che in qualche modo fa
suo il modello biomedico si chiama
modello biopsicosociale un modello
all'interno del quale l'interazione uomo
ambiente è cruciale perché stesso noi
quando abbiamo delle malattie croniche
tendiamo a considerare che questa mano
questa artrite questa mano che rende
difficile fare delle cose sia l'essenza
di una persona in realtà non a maria
vuole essere una nonna una nonna che è
utile ancora la sua famiglia sono i poté
una nonna che malgrado la sua malattia
rimane la persona che è allora affermare
che qualcuno è degno di rispetto e che
detiene dei diritti non perché disabile
ma perché persona
malgrado la malattia significa anche
chiarire che non c'è niente di buono
nella disabilità noi ricercatori la
malattia la combattiamo noi cerchiamo
qualcosa che vada contro la malattia mai
contro malato e allora è l'uomo concreto
reale malgrado la malattia la disabilità
che è degno di rispetto e in un certo
senso la teoria del malgrado che è una
teoria che è stata definita dal
professor pesino un filosofo italiano
nel 2010 ci dice che malgrado il fatto
che nessuno qui è perfetto in qualche
modo abbiamo tutti conosciuto la
malattia
per noi i nostri cari i nostri amici ma
questo non ha tolto nulla della nostra
qualità di essere uomo il fatto di
essere con una malattia con qualcosa che
ci rende facili non è che ci rende meno
quindi noi siamo uomini degni di dignità
malgrado la malattia
e allora se è vero questo modello
biopsicosociale per cui cambiando forse
l'ambiente io diminuisco la disabilità
guardando a questa interazione io forse
non posso cambiare la malattia perché
purtroppo in molte malattie le posso
curare ma non le posso guarire come
colgo lo dico perché dirigendo il centro
coma questo vedo che molte malattie
e molto difficile curare però posso
lavorare sull'altra componente che
determina la disabilità che è l'ambiente
l'ambiente che può essere facilitatore o
barriera nell'ambito del nostro
ragionamento collettivo molto spesso
l'ambiente inteso come l'ambiente
architettonico ed è chiaro per molti che
le barriere architettoniche sono un
ambiente che possa essere modificato e
si è modificato chiaramente diminuisce
una disabilità generale collettiva
perché è più accessibile e fruibile
tutto quello che attorno a noi ma in
realtà ambiente che mi interessa di più
condividere con voi oggi è l'ambiente
sociale l'ambiente delle relazioni i
vostri amici i vostri cari le persone
con cui siete accanto l'ambiente sociale
che in qualche modo ormai gli studi
stanno dimostrando in maniera
inequivocabile che avere amici essere in
relazione avere delle conoscenze avere
delle reti cambia la tua salute
se degli amici stai meglio ma non stai
meglio perché stai bene soltanto in
termini di benessere stai proprio meglio
ci sono degli studi australiani
meravigliosi in cui si dimostrano che
abbiamo una variazione nell'ambito del
dna se siamo in relazione se siamo
connessi con delle persone un grande
studio europeo che abbiamo coordinato
noi del besta di milano in cui lavoro
con i miei ricercatori abbiamo visto che
avere reti sociali ha un effetto sulla
salute se sei anziano se sei volato tu
stai peggio ma non perché sia isolato e
proprio il tuo corpo che sta male
sei proprio tu che stai male in tutti i
paesi che abbiamo studiato più di 10.000
persone che abbiamo intervistato la
famiglia era sempre il facilitatore
sostanziale mi piace chiamare tutti quei
caregiver che ho incontrato nei miei 30
anni di lavoro come neurologa i
rivoluzionari della tenerezza un
relatore di ted molto famoso che ha
usato questa espressione due settimane
fa ha chiamato rivoluzionare della
tenerezza dicendo una cosa un papà o una
mamma quando parlano al loro bambino
usando la voce da piccoli non sono meno
perché usano questa voce da piccoli sono
teneri usano la tenerezza
lui poi giustamente ha detto quando dio
è sceso e ha parlato
un uomo si è fatto di meno perché usava
la tenerezza e a me è piaciuto quando ho
sentito questa cosa perché ho pensato io
conosco un sacco di rivoluzionari quelle
madri che per 5 10 20 anni stanno vicino
al loro figlio che ha 18 anni è uscito
di casa la sera salutandolo è rimasto in
coma quelle mogli che restano vicino ai
proprietari
mi è piaciuto prima scusatemi lo devo
dire tutti quei rivoluzionari
tecnologici non quasi tutti maschi
beh io invece conosco un sacco di
rivoluzionari femmine perché le
rivoluzionarie della tenerezza sono
prevalentemente delle donne sono delle
donne che sono veramente non hanno un
grammo di meno perché si sono abbassate
a stare vent'anni senza uscire mai
perché non avevano nessun aiuto attorno
a loro alla loro casa sono state
rivoluzionare della tenerezza perché
sono state lì e non sono andate via
io li conosco questi rivoluzionari della
tenerezza chissà quanti ce ne sono in
sala qua
e allora la dignità umana appartiene
integralmente all'uomo malgrado si è
ammalato
malgrado sia inconsapevole delle proprie
capacità malgrado sia fragile malgrado
manchino delle cose la dignità e diritti
sono fondamentalmente soltanto nella sua
pura qualità di essere uomo
e allora anche quando siamo investiti da
uno tsunami da una malattia il tempo
della malattia è il tempo della vita non
è un tempo altro per moltissime persone
che vivono tanto tempo quella malattia
al tempo della malattia è la vita
e allora il malgrado cosa ci dice chi ci
ricorda che ciò da cui noi dobbiamo
partire per progettare questo tempo sono
delle relazioni significative in
malgrado allora ci insegna che è tempo
di essere un giuseppe
cinque anni fa fui chiamata dallo ms per
andare nelle filippine subito dopo lo
tsunami mi chiesero di andare a fare una
valutazione della disabilità nella
popolazione che era stata completamente
devastata da uno tsunami che conosciuto
come lo tsunami che seguiva il più forte
di foehn e della storia un vento a 300
chilometri all'ora che ha spazzato via
tutto
mi viene a prendere il collega in questo
aeroporto mezzo distrutto salgo sulla
macchina con lui e cominciamo ad andare
in mezzo allo scenario di tacloban
questa città delle filippine e questo
lascia che si presentava i miei occhi
questo è il capannone dove il comune
aveva detto andate tutti nel capannone
che vi salvate
questo è quello che è rimasto questa è
la nave che è stata spostata di un
chilometro per chi sventola così forte
lo tsunami e londra così alta che ha
messo questa nave a un chilometro dalla
riva destra nelle persone che cercavano
da mangiare perché era tutto distrutto
non c'era più niente c'erano gli aiuti e
poi improvvisamente arriva giuseppe
tutto distrutte attorno io vedo giuseppe
ristorante italiano filippino b col mio
collega ma che cos'è la sera ci andiamo
a cena
va bene andiamo a cena da giuseppe la
sera entro vedo giuseppe dico giuseppe
buongiorno piacere da dove viene da
napoli piace rico e cosa fa come mai pur
nel suo se niente allo tsunami lì dice
no io avevo tutto distrutto c'era più
niente
allora ho pensato ho chiamato tutti i
miei camerieri ho chiamato il pizzaiolo
chiamato tutti ho detto non c'è più
niente
andate a casa seppelliti i vostri morti
mettete al sicuro le vostre famiglie poi
venite qua qui fra cinque giorni
arrivano gli aiuti gli aiuti devono
mangiare se noi ricostruiamo tutti
insieme questa pizzeria
noi ce la facciamo ritirarci su fare i
soldi voi ricostruite le vostre case
però state come stati insieme
giuseppe mi ha assegnato allora una cosa
che tanti dicono che è proprio vero che
anche quando sei nel buio più totale
una sola candela fa luce e che spesso e
io ci credo profondamente nelle
situazioni anche un uomo solo fa la
differenza
ognuno spera sempre di essere quell'uomo
lì ma anche se uno non si sente
all'altezza se uno si sente inadeguato
c'è sempre la speranza che ci sia
attorno a qualcuno che possa essere
quella candela perché in qualche modo
quando si è in uno tsunami qualunque sia
lo tsunami che vivete che avete vissuto
che state vivendo che vivono i vostri
amici
io credo che sia fondamentale essere
facilitatori gli uni per gli altri
credo che sia fondamentale saper
chiedere aiuto e anche fondamentale
saperlo ricevere credo che sia
fondamentale avere coraggio e non
perdere la speranza perché qualche
candela attorno c'è allora bisogna darsi
un obiettivo assieme assieme a chi vi
vuole bene e assieme a chiamate
insomma per me è tempo di essere un
giuseppe
[Applauso]